je vais faire un jeu d'observation
vous allez mettre une musique
d'observation de musique comme on trouve
dans les ascenseurs et pendant 30
secondes je ne vais rien dire et vous
allez regarder autour de vous et vous
allez me dire chacun d'entre vous qui
n'était pas là lundi et mardi avec
encore
on est parti pour 30 secondes regardez
autour de vous ouvrez l'oeil comme on
dit et je ramasse les copines dans 30
secondes c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai bouffé une demi-heure
c'est terminé
Mathieu Delormeau n'était pas là
je le note dans un coin de ma tête
thaïlandais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut faire un système de poulie par
derrière
[Applaudissements]
en fait ils étaient vieux pour moi parce
que j'avais 18 ans mais ils avaient
presque votre âge
ouais les cars étaient grands mais si
vieux que ça donc
dans la douche
c'est la dernière fois que tu as pris la
douche avec tu avais 18 ans non non ça a
duré quand même assez longtemps donc
ça va alors ça fait au moins 35 ans
je crois que ça faisait beaucoup plus
que ça mais en tout cas tu es très belle
ok n'était pas là
il me semble que Mathieu n'était pas là
ou alors il s'est fait discret
Matthieu et il m'a manqué ah c'est
gentil
j'avais pas entendu
n'était pas là n'était pas là et puis
j'étais pas là c'est pas vrai
que Mathieu n'était pas là j'adore votre
pull je voulais juste vous le dire parce
que vraiment je l'adore
quel amour
qui n'était pas là l'ignoble traître de
Santorin
et vous avez raison c'est l'ignoble
traître de Santorin qui n'était pas là
l'ignoble au traître de Santorin
qui n'était pas là lundi mardi
et aujourd'hui
sachez que Mathieu Delormeau n'est pas à
la fête hein
j'aime les gens qui sont droits comme la
justice
cette personne Mathieu Delormeau m'a
brisé le coeur elle a joué avec oui elle
a joué avec ma confiance mais tu voulais
venir tant que c'est la confiance
d'habitude je n'ai pas l'habitude de
jeter en pâture le nom de quelqu'un qui
m'a fait du mal et c'est Mathieu
Delormeau
en Grèce en Grèce
pendant vos petits camarades sont en
train de travailler et de se tuer pour
faire des records d'audience
alors c'était aussi pour le business
voilà en Grèce
je vais avoir quand même tes photos
instant on va voir si c'est du business
donc là
apparemment tu étais en repérage d'un
lieu de tournage non
mais c'est ça donc là voilà donc là
ensuite mettez-moi la deuxième
mais un bateau pour pour voir justement
l'île mais moi c'est pour des raisons
politiques comme vous le savez on
n'était pas pour des repérages hein pour
les raisons politiques là en ce moment
je n'ai pas trop en parler mais je me
rapproche beaucoup de la graisse vous le
savez par rapport au maire de Nico
absolument par rapport à la politique
on a vérifié le maire de iconos on se
sait même pas qui c'est impossible en
plus
et alors après j'ai passé par Athènes là
je suis en train de je veux pas trop en
dire mais de me rapprocher oui voilà de
groupe politique
[Rires]
on a une dernière photo s'il vous plaît
puisque je vais demander
à chaque chronique de dire une phrase
sur l'attitude de Mathieu Desormeaux
pour décrire cette attitude et à la fin
je déciderai si je dois vous sanctionner
ou pas mais non pour cette absence lundi
mardi début de semaine on a besoin de
force on a besoin d'être tous soudé
apparemment et lui il était
tranquillement en train de manger des
gambas à Mykonos
avec qui vous êtes parti
ne montez pas non non
allez-y il y avait Guillaume mon associé
d'accord Benoît pote et voilà Benoît
Benoît un pote qu'on connaît très bien
du bois de cette expérience du bois
c'est comme mon petit frère voilà
dans le bois
[Applaudissements]
mais donc Benoît Dubois Guillaume
frisquet et vous et moi à Santorin
lâcher
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait j'ai fait
connaissance non pas du tout non non pas
du tout j'ai fait
est-ce que vous êtes déjà
allé en week-end comme ça vous avez fait
une connaissance et puis après vous
l'avez plus revu
évidemment là c'est compliqué parce que
c'était il y avait que des Américains
c'est un weekend d'intégration non non
il y avait que les Américains un peu
badweiser un peu beauf que j'ai pas j'ai
pas fait plaisir
mais c'est oui c'est vrai que c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas ce que je préfère
les Américains mais non non là ça a été
vraiment week-end contemplatif la mer
avec beaucoup de culpabilité
effectivement de ne pas être là non non
mais c'est vrai les chroniqueurs vont
dire un mot sur vous on va démarrer par
vous Béatrice parce que ce que vous avez
pas dit là ce soir c'est qu'il avait
menti donc il avait dit qu'il était en
tournage exactement alors qu'il était en
Grèce et en fait ce qui ne m'étonne pas
du tout de lui je trouve ça très
enfantin c'est un peu l'équivalent
adulte et TPMP de du de l'enfant qui a
pas fait ses devoirs et qui va dire à sa
maîtresse que son chien les a mangé
voilà d'accord
et vous pensez que c'est une bonne
intervention ça
[Applaudissements]
écoute pour une fois fait une phrase
en fait ça me choque pas parce que en
fait Mathieu et comme son public de TPMP
people le weekend il part très très loin
de la France et ça se voit le dimanche
matin à 9h
vraiment son téléphone qu'il a pris son
temps et tout et je pense que c'est très
bien pour recharger les batteries et il
reviendra beaucoup
c'est bien merci je pense qu'il va
revenir d'autant plus fort charmante
avec moi
alors
on va attendre
j'ai enquêté sur Mathieu Delormeau j'ai
quelques contacts à Santorin notamment
un serveur dans un bar qui s'appelle le
coco bingo
établissement réservé aux bodybuilders
curieux et pas farouche
Mathieu aurait été aperçu en train de
danser sur la table en remuant son
shaker de prod de manière
et il aurait fini la soirée très tard
dans la nuit dans un établissement qui
s'appelle l'Open Flamingo et il y aurait
bu quelques verres et bouffer quelques
culs
les vrais infos
[Rires]
et donc c'est une admissible si j'ai
d'autres infos je reviens vers vous dans
quel c'est quoi votre mot pour moi tu
dormais trahison vous avez été au
courant de la séquence ou pas du tout
ce que vous êtes complètement à côté là
alors on y va
moi je pense que je vais être à côté du
coup moi c'est bravo bravo Mathieu parce
qu'en fait toi tu es le caviar de TPMP
donc il faut pas en abuser il faut
devoir très peu et tu es mon idole en
fait je trouve ça vraiment formidable
que tu sois pas venu que tu es menti tu
es sors de chroniqueur anti-système un
peu rebelle ce que j'en fais des
chroniques en anticipées
il va faire mercredi jeudi vendredi et
puis voilà il sait que j'ai ça dans un
coin de ma tête Delphine on avait fait
les frais peut-être sanctionner vous
pensez
vous aviez pardonne non mais non vous me
connais non
mais écoutez vous me connaissez je vais
pas vous raconter l'histoire et je vais
pas me changer oui je vais le
sanctionner oui il va en prendre plein
la gueule oui va vivre des moments
difficiles oui il va douter oui
[Musique]
oui il va pas ça un weekend de noir oui
tout ça oui oui qu'est-ce que vous
voulez méritez si vous avez dit Siri
j'ai besoin de souffler ça va pas en ce
moment je suis en burn out est-ce que je
peux prendre deux jours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une musique
américaine la semaine prochaine elle
parle de moi
elle va faire du mettre des photos sur
internet
la sanction je vous le dis il sait qu'il
y aura sanction qu'en penses-tu soit
belle et belle femme voilà même
oui j'en veux beaucoup
vous profitez de la gentillesse de Cyril
merci chérie comment allez-vous faire
[ __ ] à Mykonos
[Applaudissements]
mamie devient folle
non mais attendez non mais jalouse
c'est inadmissible c'est étonnant mais
pour ce défonce
pour qui vous vous prenez Mathieu
Delormeau Cyril nous sommes face à un
immense scandale moral et télévisuel et
je vous demande solennellement je ne
vous demande jamais rien de prononcer
pour ce trade ce déserteur la radiation
plus récente
[Applaudissements]
les chéris
vous vous en doutez
il y a sanction
Mathieu Delormeau vous avez la sélection
vous allez être sanctionné et
sélectionner d'ailleurs
la sanction j'ai longuement réfléchi
et je me suis dit qu'est-ce qui pourrait
affaiblir et qui pourrait peiner le plus
Matthieu Delormeau lui enlever un TPMP
mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai faut vous
renouveler
50% de son salaire
je l'ai déjà fait
tout est vrai c'est horrible si les gens
savaient
la sanction
et je vous le dis cette sanction aura
lieu je vous jure que c'est vrai mais je
peux pas d'abord me défendre avant
les photos parlent d'elles-mêmes Raymond
pas parce que moi je veux je voulais pas
parler mais s'il veut se défendre je
vais parler vas-y tu veux te défendre ou
pas
mais même quelqu'un 100% coupable le
droit à une défense
ce que je voulais juste te dire bébé
juste ça
va partir de là juste ça mon cœur depuis
la rentrée je n'ai pas fait un mauvais
TPMP j'ai tout donné j'ai dansé
on peut faire un débat toi aussi on peut
faire un tour de table non non non voilà
et j'ai senti à maman que j'allais faire
une ou deux mauvaises émissions et je
n'ai pas le droit on a pas le droit
d'être médiocre à vos côtés on n'a pas
ce droit déjà non non je préfère être
absent que médiocre à vos côtés quel que
soit le salaire quoi tu vas prendre
beaucoup plus de congés
ça c'est si vous voulez je vous le dis
Raymond tu voulais lui parler après je
vous dirais la sanction non je trouve
son comportement honteux honteux parce
que il a prévenu le dimanche apparemment
je me suis renseigné il a prévenu le
dimanche qu'il serait pas là lundi mardi
et on est tout le temps là à rigoler
entre nous et c'est bien qui m'ouvre
cette porte parce qu'il me dit qu'ici
c'est un travail la preuve que c'est pas
un travail parce que dans un autre
travail si tu te barres de jour sans
prévenir état des sanctions donc je
demande monsieur Hanouna des sanctions
pour Monsieur Delormeau
elle est simple je te jure que c'est
vrai à partir de demain
à partir de demain
tu devras non occuper hein toute la
journée
demain jeudi et vendredi de Gilles
Verdez
[Applaudissements]
et pourquoi je suis jonctionnelle
non je prends la bête de sa mère
tu devras aller le chercher en limousine
mais non lui faire un soir tu lui donnes
un bras
également le acheter un petit cadeau
dans le monde du travail prend le
licenciement c'est mieux mais mon cœur
j'ai des grosses journées de ma après
demain je prépare des choses j'étais PNP
c'est ma journée dans une limousine avec
ce nain enfin c'est pas possible quand
même quoi et ben il te suffira toute la
journée
demain
il sera en bas de chez toi
dès que tu partiras il part avec toi tu
vas au bureau tu fais la réunion que il
est là il donne son avis
bien sûr je dis et vendredi d'accord
Gilles bien sûr donc il va te suivre
bien sûr il sera avec toi il faut aller
chercher fin tu préfères pas on arrête
le salaire plus je rentre de TPMP people
plus tout ce que tu veux non tu me
remercieras ah je crois pas
de quoi
bien sûr attends tu vas beaucoup
apprendre
pas du tout tu vas apprendre grave
et est-ce que je peux ajouter quelque
chose
[Applaudissements]
il ne m'a même pas dit bonjour
je lui ai dit tu ne me dis même plus
bonjour Est-ce que dans votre sanction
il peut y avoir l'obligation de me dire
bonjour Cyril je suis pas sûr vous là
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi l'appel de star on a fait ça
on pas vous apparemment pourquoi ils ont
fait ça peut-être que j'étais absent ma
femme je faisais pas beaucoup bosser
ah d'accord
[Applaudissements]